all right I'm not jealous of many people
on Earth but I think I'm jealous of
Craig Clemens because not only has he
built a successful billion dooll company
with no outside investors but he has
made hit after hit after hit and I asked
him to come on the podcast he thought it
was just going to be a normal episode
but then when we started talking I
realized that I wanted him to give me a
master class and when he's giving it to
me he's giving it to you which is to
teach us the seven ways that he as a
marketer has sold over a billion dollars
of products online he calls these the
seven human hijacks and he goes through
example after example of how great
products and things that we take for
granted like brushing your teeth or how
people eat bacon for breakfast those
weren't things people did back in the
day it was guys like him marketers that
Ed specific tactics in order to make
those a thing and if you're an
entrepreneur who's uh you know wants to
be successful you need to be good at
marketing you got to be able to sell
your product and is very rare to be able
to sit with somebody like Craig who's
actually one of the best to ever do it
and ask him how did you do it I I feel
lucky he's doing this he doesn't have to
tell us these secrets like you know I
think he's at that sweet spot where he's
been running his company for 15 years
he's been doing this for a long time
he's s you know the company's super
successful I don't feel like he has to
like guard those Secrets anymore so I
told him to give them to us and I don't
know about you but I've had professors
in school I've took marketing classes
but those were not people who have
actually been in the game done it people
have actually created category sold
hundreds of millions of dollars of
single products that a year ago nobody
had ever heard of and so Craig tells the
story of how others did it and at the
end he tells a story about how he helped
create the probiotics category if you
ever had probiotics you can thank Craig
because he was the one who created uh
that category and made it mainstream so
enjoy this marketing master class on the
seven human hijacks how marketers have
hijacked your brain with Craig
Clem what's up dude you uh I have this
Theory now of guests who come on the
podcast the more their video setup looks
like they were either taking hostage or
are like you know in some Motel
somewhere uh the better the guest is we
had bolog on and he was like white wall
nothing in the room and he was just like
you know at the time he didn't have his
like video setup like you know he was
not on his home video setup and like the
higher your IQ the worse your video
setup and the opposite is true
unfortunately for me which is the more
HD and beautiful your video setup the
less interesting things you usually have
to say yes yes and the cool thing is
you're like the real life madman you you
you're an ad guy and a copywriter who
translated those skills into a billion
dollars of sales which is why when you
were coming on this time we started
talking and we kind of realized that you
have a master class in you so normally
we hang out we just shoot the [__] about
business ideas but
occasionally we just drop a knowledge
bomb and the knowledge bomb is what we
call a master class which is just let
somebody do their thing for 30 minutes
and the cool thing about this is you
said you had given a talk internally to
your your team to your company to pump
them up and it sounded so dope that I
just said can you just please do that on
the Pod and you you agreed and so my
friend the floor is going to be yours
I'm here when you need me I might chime
in here and there but I'm really going
to let you cook during this and uh let
Craig Clemens do this master class so
take it away so Sean did you brush your
teeth this morning did you take an
elevator or are you wearing sneaks right
now any any yes one of three ain't bad
one of three ain't bad bad okay well
marketers created all of that marketers
created so much of our daily
behavior that uh people that I tell
these stories to don't even want to
accept it and you know it's it's okay
though I mean that's that's uh that's
the case for everyone you're not alone
so do you know who this guy is on the
left here I do not but he looks very
sophisticated who is that this is a this
is a smart [__] this is Sigman
Freud
oh and this gentleman on the right do
you know who that is I'm guessing you
don't I do not okay well this guy has
changed your life this guy is a man
named Edward bernes he's often called
the father of public
relations and he is actually Sigman
Freud's
nephew so I don't know uh what exactly
kind of kind of shirt you're wearing
over there Sean or if you uh put some
some style into it but this guy has his
his hands and so much stuff that he he
literally created
consumerism so quick
example before bernes people would buy
clothes you know unless you were in like
the the upper classes people would buy
clothes to go to work um he's the one
who got together with a bunch of other
people and they're like wait a second
these work clothes people aren't buying
enough of them if people use clothing
for expression then people would buy
more clothes and he got the
expression uh vibe to go all the way
down the line from anyone who could
afford clothing to be buying more
clothing and then buying more things
when they came into season and this and
that now it's people who don't have the
means that buy buy buy more clothing
they they can afford right well let me
just get into some of the the examples
here and then you'll see that this guy
was operating on a level that uh is is
unfathomable
so in this presentation I'm going to sh
with you what I've discovered studying
and creating marketing campaigns that
have caused World change and I call them
the seven human hijacks because when you
use these seven things you are hijacking
the lyic system of the brain and a human
cannot help themselves but to pay
attention and either respond or at least
Lo L what you're going to do or say into
their brain and maybe they respond the
next time but these seven hijacks I'm
going to share each of them after I
share these marketing campaigns and
you're going to see how they repeat and
not every campaign uses all seven but um
you'll see that some of them are
extremely powerful and then when you put
them all together that's when you can
really do this type of thing yourself so
if you're watching this right now and
you're excited about you possibly
changing the world forever this is the
recipe let's
go our software is the worst have you
heard of HubSpot see most crms are a
cobble together mess but HubSpot is easy
to adopt and actually looks gorgeous I
think I love our new CRM our software is
the best HubSpot grow better okay one of
the most interesting marketing campaigns
of all time was created by a guy named
Claude Hopkins so Claude Hopkins was
approached by a a toothpaste company
called pepsin and they said Claude we
want to sell more of our
toothpaste and he looked at the lay of
the land and he realized there was a
problem he said to pepson he said Look
only 5% of people brush their teeth on a
daily basis so why are you even in this
business that not a lot of uh people are
taking part do you believe that Sean
1920s 95% of the women that you kiss are
going to have terrible breath no one
brushed their teeth
back then and so Claude tells the the
founders of pepid and he's like look if
you guys really want to sell some
toothpaste you're going to have to get
people brushing their teeth and so he
created this masterful ad campaign that
built Pepsi it into the the dominating
toothpaste brand for for decades and
this is the ad the ad says the film that
discolors the whitest teeth and then he
has you do a demonstration so do this
with me Sean take the tip of your tongue
put it over the the the fronts put it
over those gold fronts you got under
there okay do you feel that
film there on your teeth yeah I kind of
do kind of do so the ad goes on to say
that brushing with pepsodent is going to
remove that film and behind that film is
a movie star
smile and it's so genius right because
everybody wants that movie star Smile
everybody has that film whether you just
brushed your teeth five minutes ago or
not then you feel that you're like oh
shoot I got this film you know and then
it talks about how pepid it is the way
to get rid of that film so the result of
this ad within a decade 85% of Americans
didn't brush their teeth on a daily
basis and pepid is still around today um
they ran this ad campaign for I don't
know 50 years something like that um and
I'll tell you something interesting is
is about 10 years in there was other
companies trying to compete with pepan
and they were using a similar ad
campaign you know it's very common to
Steel an ad campaign but they couldn't
get the repeat orders and they did a a
focus group and they found out that
people love Pepsi because it had this
like minty flavor that made their mouth
tingle after they brushed with it and
then the toothpaste companies the other
ones started knocking that off and when
people felt the tingle then they would
stick with other companies otherwise
they'd try the other when they would
feel wouldn't feel the tingle and they'd
be like oh it's not actually working you
know so they'd go right back to pepsin
it so they they owned it for like 10
years and then it got actually
competitive because then people were not
only stealing their ads they were
stealing uh you know their their secret
of the tingle so one of the the human
hijacks that Claude Hopkins used one he
sold the dream of the movie star smile
and you're going to see this theme
reoccurring throughout this
presentation uh second he created a
powerful demonstration that anyone could
do and that's just rubbing your tongue
over the the front of your teeth and
then the next thing he did is he made it
about them he made it about the
potential user and this is a a big thing
that uh a lot of companies mess up is
they just talk about their own product
and you know why they're so excited
about it but they don't talk about why
it's going to be exciting for the user
and Claude did a really great job of
that sharing how it's going to give them
that movie star smile so that's that's
like the there's this diagram that I
love that's like um I call it the Mario
marketing I don't know who originally
created this I saw it from that company
buffer but I I don't know if they
created it originally but it's little
Mario um you know Mario when he's small
then it's the fireflower and then when
Mario gets the fireflower he's able to
shoot Fireballs out of you know out of
his hands he's running around he's huge
he can shoot fireballs and basically it
says uh don't sell this the fireflower
which is your product sell this which is
the customer going from little Mario to
being big Mario who can shoot Fireballs
right and it's like that's what you want
to sell is how the user will be more
badass rather than all the features and
uh facets about your product yes exactly
so think about benefits what's the
benefit what's in it for them you know
these people are busy right now Sean I
think people see something like 4,000
ads a
day and they did a study and it showed
that the human brain has the um uh same
int span as a goldfish is like less than
you know uh uh the ability of a goldfish
to pay attention so how do you grab
their attention well you have to talk
about something that's exciting to them
something that keeps them up at night or
something that they you know have a deep
dream hope and desire for so I want to
get back to that demonstration though
where did Claud get the idea for this
demonstration so
1854 there's a guy named Otis and Otis
gets into the elevator business and he
didn't invent the elevator but he came
up with a a breaking system for the
elevator so back then people were afraid
to use elevators because every once in a
while just like today you hear about a
car accident you'd hear about an
elevator accident where you know people
get on and the elevator falls down right
so Otis creates his great braking system
first year out he only sells three
elevators the next year out he sells
Seven elevators like no one cares you
know he doesn't doesn't uh have the
ability to get the word out and then he
meets this guy named PT
Barnum and so everyone probably now
knows uh PT Barnum one of the the
greatest uh marketing and showmen of all
time and PT baram says this is what
we're going to do we're going to go to
the Crystal Palace in New York City
which was this big exhibition Hall and
we're going to do a grand demonstration
so Otis gets up there on this Elevator
Shaft
and he has his assistant get up there
with an axe and so he's standing on it
the the elevator goes up the shaft just
like it normally would in a building and
he's like cut the cord Jimmy he goes
boom but he cuts the first cord the
elevator drops like just a little bit
and then there's one more cord hanging
and everyone's looking out they're like
oh [__] what's he gonna do you know this
is the cord and then puts actually the
second cord and the El only two feet and
stops
he's like all safe here gentlemen all
safe those are like like famous words
that were published in the newspaper all
safe here and it showed that Otis had
invented a breaking system for elevators
that worked so over the next decade he
sold 2,000 elevators he got all the
greatest commissions he did the the eiel
tower the Empire State Building and even
today if you look at your
elevator I've found about half of the
elev I get into have this little Otis
logo is still crushing all my zippers
all my zippers say YKK and all my
elevators say Otis that's all those are
the only two things I know yeah so uh so
that's the power of a great
demonstration so what did what did Otis
do the the powerful demonstration stands
in people's minds and he also made it an
event you know so what's greater about
an event
well one people are going to show up and
two it's going to get covered by the
newspaper but if you think about it on
on a more Primal level have you ever
heard the phrase Sean nothing attracts a
crowd like a
crowd no but I like that one of my
favorite favorite sayings and it it just
shows that humans cannot resist an event
you know if you're walking down the
street and then you see like a big crowd
of people and something's going on over
there and there's a band or whatever
it's like you got to see what what's
going on it's just just natural and so
if you make your advertising an event
then people cannot not pay attention to
it and then he also showed
unquestionable
proof using that demonstration and
putting his own body on the elevator he
didn't use a dummy he didn't use a
monkey himself was on that elevator
while his assistant was was cutting the
cords and so that's the type of
unquestionable proof that lead people to
go ahead and take take a uh Act to buy
without questioning it and of course he
made it about them he didn't get up
there and show his fancy breaking system
or how it worked you know he addressed
the fear in everyone's mind that was
about the safety of of getting on an
elevator and he did it with the powerful
demonstration so let show you uh let me
show you something hold
on
all right do you know this brand mini
Katana have you seen them Craig I have
not all right so I about to uh YouTube
don't be alarmed this is inside here is
a giant
sword and um this company so this brand
they sell these it's called mini Katana
but it's actually humongous so they sell
these swords now the problem with
selling swords is that Google and
Facebook don't let you do it you can't
advertise weapons so how does an
e-commerce brand work when you can't
advertise weapons well what they did was
they started they hired like 20
YouTubers and ticktockers and they would
have them do what you just described the
powerful demonstration so they would
take this they would take this sword and
they would instead of saying you know
why you need a sword because most people
don't need a sword let's be honest uh
instead of talking about how long it is
or how sharp it is or whatever they
would show that the sword could cut
through a bullet that was fired at them
so this video starts with a guy's
holding the sword and there's a bullet
aimed at him and he's going to try to
split it in half and uh then when he
does it it's a powerful presentation
about like how badass these swords are
and they all of their marketing they'll
take a steak you just see a steak plop
down on a cutting board and then a giant
sword cutting through it which is
completely unnecessary but it is a
powerful demonstration um and you know I
I remember seeing those TED Talks where
guys take a glass and they you know it's
like here's dirty water would you drink
this water it's like no way and then
they put it into their filter and like
their bottle filter and then they start
to drink it I don't know who this was
Bill Gates or something chugs in the
water first right for for real yeah
exactly they make it disgusting and then
the whole crowd is gasping and like they
could tell you how the filter works or
they could show you that they're willing
to drink the water through this filter
that was like disgusting water and I
still remember that was like 20 years
ago I still remember that video because
it's just you're right it hijacked my
brain yeah the The Knife Company they're
genius any knife infomercial will do
this where they'll be taking a knife and
cutting a penny you know or like
effortlessly slicing tomatoes through
the air and you know who was uh the king
of this was Dr Oz Dr Oz what did he do
every episode of The Dr Oz Show is a
marketing master class he advertised oh
[__] I'm sleeping on Dr Oz yeah he
advertised these nutrients and I don't
know if he had some type of deal with
manufacturers or something like that but
he would advertise like um like
Resveratrol or like um Garcinia camboia
berries which were like weight loss but
he wouldn't ever advertise a specific
brand he would just talk about Garcinia
camboia if you look one of the reasons
it's hard to advertise supplements
online is because Dr Oz would go and
talk about Garcinia camboia or whatever
Barry and then all these scammers would
create
websites uh selling Garcinia camboia on
auto ship that you could never get out
of you know you'd sign up website some
would disappear but that thing would be
docking your credit card for years later
you know whatever so Dr o one of the
ones I remember is he'd go on there and
he'd say this is your body and these
balloons on it and then You' have like a
mannequin with with balloons on it these
balloons are the fat
cells oh wow Ginia camboia is a miracle
berry that works for any body
type and then he take out a Pinn he'd be
like this is the berry
pop pop that's what Garcinia camboia
does to the fat cells in your
body and C man like a billion dollars of
Garcinia Cambodia we stole over the next
few months mostly to these scammy Auto
billing marketers it was it was wild and
he did this with like five different
berries over time and eventually he got
pulled into Congress to testify and all
this [__] and like way lose he rolled
with it cuz he was getting all these
allegations that he was starting on one
episode he goes uh he gets a camera crew
behind him and he goes down to one of
the companies that's selling the
Garcinia camboia and he knocks in the
door he's got the camera behind him the
founder comes out he's like hey I didn't
give you permission to use my name and
likeness to sell your garc camboia and
like your autoing customers and this and
that you know and he was like pretending
that he was the the good guy but I don't
know man I don't know if like India was
lining his pockets or something before
it happened but like this was so many
berries and for so many years uh it it
it's crazy man it was like billions of
dollars a fraud happened because of
because of his show you know you know
what I love about this is um a lot of
the audience who listens to this and a
lot of the people I know who are uh
entrepreneurial or technical type
engineering type people often so um
rational and logical and like sort of
analytical about the way that they want
to about the way they see the world and
so the idea that hey we're going to do
this event with the the axe swinging at
the the Rope or you know we're going to
blow up these balloons and they'll be
like well that's not what the fat cell
looks like that's way too big that's not
to scale um you know like you have to
almost you have to use the other part of
your brain if you're going to do this
you have to make something powerful
visual dramatic and those are not skills
that typically your kind of um
operational or technical person is used
to flexing and so what I love about this
is these examples that give you
inspiration to be able to like go use
that other part of your brain you know
if you look at these we got the hijacks
up here right from Otis Elevator all of
these apply to what I just said about
dog draw the event is that it's a TV
show you know so that makes an event
already the
demonstration the unquestionable proof
is him he's a doctor saying that this is
going to work for you and then making it
about them he said this is the miracle
weight loss cure for all body types like
those are almost his exact words and by
the way you know who else does this
amazingly well Elon Elon who's the you
know the scientist the hardcore engineer
you know what he's brilliant at just
yesterday the news was um there's the
they're getting they're hyping
cybertruck right now and you do did you
see that news that came out which was
that they unloaded a full magazine of
some assault rifle at the door and so
there's a bunch of holes in the door or
like you could see where the bullet hit
the door but didn't go through and so
he's driving that car around and leaked
that kind of the Tweet rumor that hey
they tested it this way and he did this
at their onstage event too but it it
[__] up like he tried to take a
sledgehammer and show how indestructible
this was he swung the sledgehammer and
then they like broke through the window
and he's like oh [__] that wasn't
supposed to happen like this is supposed
to be bulletproof but um he was trying
to do that he was trying to you know PT
Barnum uh you know their cyber truck
which is which is really really cool to
see yeah you know what was another
incredible success that I think was
complete [__] was the the Power
Balance bracelet do you remember those
it was like dude I was thinking about
when you did the the tongue on the teeth
that's the first thing I thought of
where people used to say hey hold out
your arms yeah and now watch how EAS I
go on one foot watch how easily I could
tip you
over then you put this bracelet on it's
just magic angle which way you press on
the arm yeah recently and he was doing
that with me and I was like oh God am I
getting schemed by this this
chiropractor but yeah I think Power
Balance actually got popped for that as
they they deserved um but that was that
was a a very effective technique even
though it was you know unethical in that
case yeah okay let's get into some uh so
those those are last two are for good
right we want people to brush their
teeth we want elevators to be safe uh
now let's talk about some evil campaigns
all right so okay 1930s all the the men
had come back from the war you know and
they gave them free cigarettes so like
so many men were hooked on smoking that
there was no room for growth so the
cigarette company has come to Eddie BR a
Lucky Strike in particular is who who
came to him and they're like hey we need
more customers he's like well you
already got all the men but at that time
Sean it was illegal for a woman to smoke
in public it was literally [__]
illegal and there was like cafes in New
York City where you know there's there's
stories of of like High Society women
getting asked to leave
and then women that could afford it
would have like special smoking rooms in
their homes that would you know that
that really liked it because they
weren't allowed to do it in public oh
and I should add something too women
didn't really want to smoke uh Mo for
the most part you know they they weren't
really pushing back against it yes it
was illegal but it was also considered a
ladylike it was a it was a man thing you
know so he says to Lucky Strike he's
like look you know you got to you got to
get the women smoking so what was going
on at the time was the women's Rights
Movement you know so women were out in
the streets marching about you know
wanting the right to vote and and Bern
is capitalized on that so the big social
event of the day kind of like the Oscars
of today was the Easter Parade which
would go down Fifth Avenue and all the
reporters would be standing on the
sidelines and so bernes organized a
float and he called up all of the the
socialites and debutants like the Paris
Hill and Kim Kardashians of the day and
he got them all to go on this float and
they're cruising down Fifth Avenue the
parades happening you know when they get
to the corner where all the reporters
were the
women do uh go into their stocking they
pull out cigarettes put them in their
mouths and light them up so imagine you
know Paris and uh Chloe and all the
Kardashians and even all the Jenners on
one float they all just start blazing up
right and the repor like what is going
on here this is this is obscene you know
women aren't supposed to do this bernes
and his crew went around to the
reporters and they said oh no no no
they're not
smoking they are
declaring their rights with these
torches of Freedom oh wow and so the
newspapers ran with that they're like
you know uh women uh present torches of
freedom to show that they are equal with
men and they can smoke
too and so turned it into a
movement and if you think about smoking
to this day if you think about a women
uh a woman who smokes um I think about
bit older than you Sean but I think of
like Kate Moss and like the you know
sexy model smoking now it might be
considered gross for a woman to smoke
again you know anyone to smoke I don't
really know what the kids these days are
thinking but yeah we you know you think
like some like badass badass woman and
you remember that old movies with Audrey
heurn you know that famous scene I think
it's breakfast at Tiffy where she's
puffing that long cigarette you know so
yeah completely change the world there
that's amazing I had never heard that
story um uh but I love that that's like
a combination of you got the event you
have kind of newsjacking which was
jumping on uh to an existing Trend but
then also um the the just the
copyrighting of the the words there of
you know these aren't cigarettes these
are torches of Freedom that's really
really powerful yeah the plants if you
like that plant strategy Ryan Holliday
wrote a great book called trust me I'm
lying and he talks about all these
phrases that he planted in the the heads
of these reporters when he was promoting
things like uh Tucker Max books and and
you know wild stuff back there so
there's a new lesson in here uh new
hijack so to speak and that is help them
Rebel or feel Superior so people have
this tendency in them they want to go
against the
grain they want to show that they are
not one of the sheep you know they want
to show that they are not going to bow
down to the the mainstream pressure or
Society standards things like that you
know and this is a really powerful
concept that you're going to see appear
throughout uh some of the the other
demonstrations here but that's that's
what ber has allowed them to do is is
Rebel and and maybe even feel superior
to the rest because they're they're
leading the charge right okay keep going
by the way I'm loving this so keep going
all right so berne's had a
problem Lucky
Strike uh did this big campaign to get
women to start smoking and they did
start smoking but they didn't smoke
Lucky Strikes because if you remember
boop boop boop see the Lucky Strike
package there Sean what color is the
main color it's
Green Well green was a very undesirable
color back in those days it was
considered an ugly color and so Bernay
got all these women smoking but lucky is
like what the [__] bernes they're not
smoking Lucky Strikes so he has to come
up with something new so he goes back to
his his debutants and and socialites and
as they say here women of prominence and
they create the first ever Gala green
ball at the Waldorf Hotel in New York
City and the magazine started following
around the Kardashians of the day to see
what type of outfits they were going to
wear that were styled in green and women
started bringing green Decor into their
homes and it just became a a big thing
and the gala happens and the women are
photographed and their exotic green
outfits and it it became the most
fashionable
color within one year going from the the
ugliest color the most fashionable color
and Lucky Strike without even trying
became the number one selling brand Sig
regets for women because they
subconsciously wanted that green box
holy [__]
wow is one of the hijacks by the way
using people of prominence or you didn't
you don't include that in the in the
hijacks unquestionable proof that falls
under unquestionable proof it's a great
question but yes when we humans see
someone as they just said in the New
York Times article someone of prominence
doing something we automatically assume
it's been we automatically assume it's
okay and we automatically have something
in us that makes us want to do that
maybe it's from when we were all in trib
and you know if the chief is doing
something then you do it too who knows
but that's that's unquestionable proof
you know so uh you know he made an event
where this unquestionable proof happened
and also there was this force that that
they wanted to rebel against you know
these celebrities are like oh I'm cool
enough where I can wear green and it'll
look good you know you know I heard this
other other thing Sean today so how old
are you are you public with your age
yeah yeah I'm 35 35 okay I'm 44 so when
you think of emojis what do you think
about when I think of emojis yeah like
who do you think uses emojis I would
have said like teenagers teens and
tweens uh but I think but then I see
people in India like my auntie my aunts
and and my aunts are crazy about about
emojis yes I would have thought the same
so my my buddy is a a dad the two
teenagers he said they will not use
emojis because they think emojis are
something adults
use they do not want to be associated
with the adults so kids these days they
don't use emojis they'll just use like
different text characters and things
like that so you've probably seen these
little like one to two or sorry two to
three character terms that they use like
tbh or like you know it stands for to be
honest or F FR which means like for real
you know they use those type of things
to separate themselves from the adults
you know people want to push back it's a
it's a natural human instinct yeah when
um when Snapchat came out was getting
really popular one of the things that uh
I remember in Silicon Valley all the
like product genius blogger guys were
like yeah you know what what snapshat
should do is make it easier to use
because look at this like uh at the time
like you know to use those face filters
you had to like there was no button on
the screen you had to just hold down on
your face for 3 seconds like a magic
trick like like a secret door that you
didn't know that nobody else knew about
um or even just in signing up there was
like all these like funky ways to do it
and um and then the people I think one
of the guys at Snapchat came out was
like look it's intentional we want you
know you know you baby proof medicine
we're we're Boomer proofing this app
like the way that this is going to
become really popular amongst young
people is that we don't make it easy for
older people to get in and figure out
how this whole thing works and we want
to make it easy for one friend to tell
another the secret on how to do
something so that they feel like they're
in on it with with them and it's like a
word of mouth virality of how do you do
that exactly it's like once your parents
and your grandma got on Facebook it
wasn't cool anymore you know right and
then everyone went to Instagram and now
you know Uncle Bob's on Instagram and
it's just like L you know so every go
Tik Tok right and we'll see if something
comes next you know I think the the moms
are well moms are definitely a big group
on Tik Tok now um I don't know if like I
don't know are you on Tik Tok I'm I'm
not I I have like a I got to admit I I
love Tik Tok even though you know it's
my lucky strike I know I know I probably
shouldn't be be smoking that Tik Tok
every night but I do well you know Tik
Tok is crack it is digital crack very
well-designed digital crack so don't
blame yourself people say that but like
when I think when they say that they
mean avoid it and I'm like wait cracks
like isn't crack supposed to be like the
greatest experience when people do it
and then I open up Tik Tok and I start
swiping yeah well you know actually
speaking of drugs funny enough there's
another Rebellion I'm seeing in in my
Community against alcohol right now and
and I
remember in my 20s that it was all about
the alcohol you know if you didn't show
up uh if you should up a party
empty-handed you know it's like not cool
I've gone to parties now with a bottle
and they'd be like oh this is a
non-alcoholic party can you go put that
back in your
car it's like push back you know um how
figure out some
Camy yeah
exactly okay last campaign I'm going to
share with you about uh Eddie Bern's is
the Great American
breakfast so early in the you know 19th
century uh 20th century breakfast was
like some coffee and and maybe a roll or
some oatmeal or something like that
right no one actually had like a actual
hearty breakfast and Beachnut bacon
comes to bir and they're like hey we
want to sell more bacon he's like well
people are eating bacon usually for
dinner sometimes for lunch there's
another meal here we can take advantage
of so bernes goes to uh his his OnStaff
doctor or actually no it was it was a it
was Beach that's OnStaff doctor and he
says hey Doc would you agree that a
hearty breakfast containing bacon would
be the best way to start your day and
the doctor is like oh of course I agree
with you do you think some of your
doctor friends would agree so he has him
write 5,000 letters to doctors Across
the Nation saying hey I think bacen is
the healthiest breakfast and people
should be eating a heartier breakfast do
you agree 4,500 doctors wrote back and
they're like yes I agree that makes
perfect sense they didn't turn this into
an ad campaign but what they did do is
they shared that result with all of the
newspapers and so newspapers started
publishing headlines doctors agree a
hearty breakfast containing bacon is the
best way to store energy to last
throughout your workday and but that's
how people started eating eating bacon
for breakfast and you know all the all
the bacon companies started going crazy
because it became a breakfast thing wow
so what are we doing here there we're
selling the dream you know of of a
breakfast that's going to give you more
energy to get throughout your day you
know so that's making it about them as
well the unquestionable proof 45 100
doctors can't be wrong right and then
there's even a little bit of a um
feeling Superior here because if your
buddy is over there eating a roll you're
like hey Sean got something to tell you
about that roll man it's not as hearty
is this your bacon right so it Taps into
all these these same psychological
hijacks you keep seeing them over and
over Okay so let's take a step back now
uh a couple decades to the 19
1910s orange juice now I grew up in the
' 80s and my mom had us drink orange
juice every day for vitamin C was this a
thing Sean when when you were a kid
totally totally orange juice is when I
was a kid orange juice is good for you
it's vitamin C which is you know good
for your immunity this is what I was
told and uh drank a lot of sugar because
of that yeah so orange juice actually
has a same amount of sugar as a
Coca-Cola so orange juice you know it's
it's glucose or something I don't know
it's a different kind of sugar but it
ain't good for you so this was all the
the result of a a marketing man named
Albert Lasker who was probably the uh
the man responsible for more consumer
change um in the early 1900s than anyone
Claud Hopkins pepson Claude actually
worked with Albert he was his top
copywriter and prior to Claude coming on
board Albert was contacted by the
California growers association they're
like Al Albert we got so many oranges
here in California we them to cut down
trees because they overproduce and then
we need to get rid of them and it brings
the bugs and all that stuff you know how
can we sell more oranges and I looked at
the L of land and all these orange
growers were competing against each
other trying to say like we have the
best orange we have the best orange or
whatever he goes okay first of all you
guys are all teaming up and so he teamed
them all up together and he put them
under one brand name and he called it
Sunkissed which I think is a pretty
genius name yes and then as he's he's
meeting with him he notices that what
the The Growers would do for their kids
as a as a as a special treat is they'd
take that orange and they they'd squeeze
it into a cup and they'd give their kids
little little shots of the juice he's
like ah wait a second how many oranges
did it take to make that juice and
they're like oh you know three or four
or whatever so we thought what if if we
could make that mainstream because the
juice tasted really good and so he had a
uh engineer invented this device that
you could you know cheap plastic device
that you can put an orange on and then
he created this campaign talking about
how oranges have all these vitamins in
them and you know will help you get more
of your nutrients from
food tying orange juice to
meals so you think about oh well I want
to get the nutrients in this food so I
want to drink orange juice with it and
then you have this campaign where you
buy box oranges and you send in your
your proof of purchase and they send you
this juicer thing so it was like you get
something for free
and created orange juice and so what is
he doing he's selling the dream of
getting the more nutrients from your
food the uh um unquestionable proof you
know if you if you go and actually read
that ad there was like you know doctors
recommend and and things like that um he
made it about them because it's showing
them that they can get some benefit here
and then here's a new hijack that's
appearing for the first
time um actually maybe I mean I guess it
would apply to toothpaste but uh Change
Daily
Behavior if you can change someone's
daily
Behavior you can create something big so
two modern examples of this Bulletproof
Coffee are you familiar with Bulletproof
Coffee uh I'm just familiar with it from
the surface level but yeah tell me tell
me about you know what do you know what
it is it's like the butter coffee or the
oil coffee MCT oil coffee is that what
it is so you walk into any Starbucks in
the country They don't serve Bulletproof
Coffee but they know what it is everyone
knows what it is and the genius that
that Dave asey had
was he changed the behavior of these of
of people that were already doing
something he kind of like like
intercepted their coffee it's an
additive to your coffee rather than a
new new Behavior so so now he's he's
changing the existing Behavior yes
changing the existing behavior and
so there's a there's a book called The
Miracle morning and it talk uh talks
about the power of journaling every day
so you buy this book called The Miracle
morning and then you do this specific
journal every day right long after you
read the book and I met the author of
that Hal Elrod and he told me something
that that stuck with me I thought was
fascinating he said when was the last
time you recommended a book and I was
like well I was just read this book on
gangas Khan you know I've been telling
all my friends about it or whatever he's
like when were you telling them about it
I was like well I was telling them about
it when I was reading it he said okay
well most people recommend books during
the the time they're reading that book
and then they go and they read the next
book right now I'm reading elon's
biography it's great that's why I just
told you about that Sean I'm literally
in the middle of it you know I can tell
you what book I read last month or last
year people talk about the things
they're doing now so if you change their
daily Behavior like Hal did with getting
people to journal in the morning they
they talk about it all the time so that
book has sold hundreds of thousands of
copies or maybe even Millions by now um
because this is 10 years ago he told me
this because people are doing this
Behavior every day and so they're
talking about it every day like oh what'
you do today I just did my morning uh
Miracle journaling like oh what's that
you know so long after the book is
through so if you change daily Behavior
it has a a viral effect that is
Untouchable by anything else love that
okay so let's get to some more modern
examples the 1970s Sean do you know who
this guy is um no some some Runner I
don't know who it is okay so this this
guy's before our time but uh gentleman's
name Steve
Prefontaine and
Prefontaine was uh best comparison I can
think of is like the Michael Phelps of
his time you know no one was really
thinking about swimming until Michael
Phelps came around who was such a
dominant athlete from the USA you know
so everyone wanted to get behind him so
Prefontaine was that guy for running and
Prefontaine had all these great quotes
like Mohamad Al Ali he's like you know
yeah someone can beat me but if you're
going to beat me you g to have to bleed
you know and he's like if you don't run
until you until you feel like you're
going to you're going to die you're not
honoring your gift you know so he had
all these great quotes he was a great
media figure he won every college record
from like 500 meter up to 2,000 meter
Prefontaine was the man and Nike was
just coming up that actually just
started like making their going from
being at a distributor making their own
shoe and fortunately Prefontaine was in
Oregon so were they and they got him to
to wear their shoes and it was a a big
thing
because the
unquestionable proof now you've got pre
Fontaine the top runner in the country
wearing Nike shoes um tragically
Prefontaine passed in a car accident
before he could go and and honor his
Olympic Glory but before he did that he
really put Nike on the map because you
know running was his thing running
what's the one accessory that you need
shoes and so this was such a big
deal um that it actually Chang the
entire industry so so prior to
Prefontaine Prefontaine was around in
like the 70s right um if you read Phil
Knight's book he talks about if you went
jogging in like the 40s 50s or
60s people were like throwing bottles at
you from your car because they're just
like mad they're like what is this idiot
doing you know he's in the road or
whatever and it was just like really
hated
upon and pre Fontaine comes along and
running actually comes cool again and so
Nike got to ride that that tailwind and
then what also happened is is back then
the people were wearing shoes that were
like uh you know kind of like the loafer
or work shoe or or whatever like pretty
basic shoes and people wanted to rebel
against that rebel against the shoes
that their dad was wearing and so they
started wearing these athletic shoes
these running shoes as a part of their
daily attire to make a statement that
like I'm rebelling and I'm
superior and it changed the entire shoe
market now athletic shoes are probably
the best selling shoe and only a tiny
percent of them are warn for athletic
activities and then it all started in
the in the 70s with with pre Fontaine
and then of course Nike had the amazing
campaign with Jordan which was more
unquestionable proof you know making
them feel super because they got the
best basketball shoe and sell the dream
that they're going to be able to fly
Like Mike so that was a a world changing
campaign that not a lot of people think
about when they put on their kicks every
morning you know you know one of those
that's I feel like is happening right
now in a small way um so you remember
like I don't know 10 years ago or
something like that those Vibram Five
Finger shoes were like getting popular
do you remember those yeah so like you
would see one and you'd be like what is
this person wearing a foot glove like
what is this thing and then they would
immediately go into the spiel about why
this is better for you and like how they
do whatever and I think this is like I
I've seen this a lot now there's um a
popular YouTuber or or Instagram guy
called knees over toes guy and he's
basically like it's like a rebellion
he's like have any of you ever been told
when you're working out like don't let
your knee go over your toe when you're
squatting because it's bad form he's
like [__] like um I had all these
knee surgeries nobody could tell me how
to fix it I fixed it myself because I
started training that way specifically
so it's like a rebellion against the
fitness industry then he's like a
rebellion against Nike cuz now Nike's
the big bad like the incumbent and so
he's like uh Nike shoes are like wearing
high heels um you you know you shouldn't
have uh these like huge heeled shoes you
should have low Drop flat shoes
basically and so he came out with his
own shoe but also there's just like a
bunch of these Brands now that are kind
of like uh flat more like you're walking
barefoot uh barefoot shoes like you're
walking on on the ground and it's funny
that like now Nike is the big kind of
status quo that they want to rebel
against and point out why why you
shouldn't be wearing Nike shoes because
of this other reason do 5,000 doctors
agree that the Nike uh you know cushion
is actually bad for you so yeah so uh
you know big one was uh MacBook launched
this ad that was called 1984 and it
aired during the Super Bowl and it it uh
was a big Rebellion against IBM everyone
was using these ibms and MacBook came
out and they're like we're the new thing
you know and I think I got the idea from
this Volkswagen ad right here so
Volkswagen when they came out I think it
was uh in the 60s all those cars were
huge you know you think of like the 60
uh7 Chevys you know these huge cars that
you couldn't get into a parking spot and
had all this extra stuff on them that
you didn't need they came out with this
think small campaign that absolutely
crushed it and it was like the the
Hipster statement at the time was to to
drive a VW bug you know and made it one
of the bestselling cars um there's
another ad that just came out from
someone who's a master of this that's
Trump so this is another video that that
I would suggest you play if you can
because it's really fascinating and they
show Hillary talking about how the Trump
people ha have to be deprogrammed have
you seen this ad it just came out like
two days ago no I haven't seen it so
what what is
it with Trump taking a commanding lead
and bomic hurting American
families genius Hillary Clinton has come
up with a way for Biden to win there
needs to be of formal deprogramming of
the cult members formal deprogramming of
the cult members
deprogram deprogramming mult
members a brilliant
plan and here's what that would look
like heay attention Joe Biden will
defeat him is the
answer this did not
happen Biden has done an amazing job
amazing
job but there's one small problem the
basket of deplorables deplorables Deora
deplorables working Americans aren't
idiots and they know who's on their side
to American workers watching their take
home pay shrink and watching inflation
destroy their family and their lives to
all of you I have your
back
I'm Donald J Trump and I approve this
message wow that's so well done I mean
love him or hate him that the man is a
master
marketer and he just rallies his base to
to rebel against uh you know the the in
um incumbents what's the word the the
elites the kind of the status quo yeah
do you think uh like in this case do you
think Trump has input on any of that or
this is just they hire some Ad Agency
that does these things like is he the
master marketer or he's hiring Master
marketers I mean he he he makes the
sound bites you know that sound bite I
think was live from a speech that they
plugged it at least it looks like it
was and you know a lot of times these
speech writers they think about that so
there's a famous uh um speech Bama did
yes we can do you remember that speech
yep yep of course that was a huge one
when when the speech writer first
presented Obama with yes we can Obama
didn't like it he didn't want to give
that speech he thought it was too basic
he's like I don't want to repeat the
same thing over and over you know the
the audience deserves something more
intelligent and they had to convinced
him to do this yes we can speech and
present it as a rally cry and finally
like okay fine you know it goes out and
gives a speech and that's sound bite man
I think it was uh will I am turn that
into that music video that went crazy
you know right it's just uh a really
powerful sound bite and and I find that
the best
politicians end up speaking in sound
bites makes Trump so effective at what
he's doing the Blogger Scott Adams if
anybody wants to kind go deeper on this
the Blogger Scott Adams who created
Dilbert he when Trump was running in
2016 and nobody thought he would win
Scott Adams was one of the first people
I saw that came out and was like of not
only can he win he will win in a
landslide which is what exact which is
what happened and he explained he goes
Trump has verbal kill shots um you know
he has these phrases that he'll say
about opponents where he'll be like um
low energy Jeb Bush and then you can
never look at Jeb again and see anything
but low energy and Jeb's so offended by
it that he feeds the energy into that uh
like you know he starts to be flustered
by it and then he starts to try to up
his energy and then Trump Pat him on the
head be like well at least you're trying
now Jeb yeah that's good you're trying
to pick up your energy I like that and
he would just destroy candidates with
like you know crooked Hillary um you
know and he would just just brand people
in a one shot kill with with with these
phrases and even the one you that video
you just showed that kind of I have your
back like you know he he's very very
good at just repeating simple messages
and and branding himself one way and and
positioning himself against the others
the other way all right
so the 80s here's a a Force for good so
did you know uh Sean the phrase uh have
one for the road do you know where that
came
from no but now that I think about it
kind of a [__] up phrase huh so I
would think that the the worst use of
that phrase would be go and have one and
then go drive but it actually meant take
a beer in your car and drink it while
driving away from uh wherever you're
going right so drunk driving was out of
control and a c uh uh campaign was
created friends don't let friends drive
drunk and it had three things to do
drive your friend home have your friend
sleep over or call a cab you know and
this cut drunk driving in half it it it
was something like a 40 to 50% uh drunk
driving decrease when this started going
around that's like U Craig if I say the
phrase this is your brain on drugs what
do you think of yeah you think of that
fried egg a powerful demonstration right
an egg hitting a frying pan sizzling
like and that was how long ago that was
like it had to been I was a kid like I
was that was 20 plus years ago and it
still has hijacked my brain where if I
if I see an egg I think about drugs or
if I hear this is your brain on drugs I
hear the egg right like uh that that is
so powerful how that worked these
powerful demonstrations are
Unforgettable you'll never look at a
sword and not think about the sword
slicing through the bullet yeah there's
something about it that that really
sticks in in the human mind maybe it's a
way we are taught how to learn you know
uh I have a I have a daughter now and
she's learning
physics not the way I think of physics
and it's not something I thought but you
know you have kids too you see how they
learn the way blocks fit together and
gravity and all of this you know it
teaches you a lot about how the human
brain learns and if you think about what
these demonstrations are they're they're
really physics demonstrations so it's
like that's how we've been learning
since age zero you know and and right we
need that foundational physics to
survive and you really notice it in
babies like they need to know that if
they're crawling and there's something
here that it's going to hurt if they hit
it like it's so basic but the kids don't
know that they actually have to learn
that you know and you think about I I
always always like why don't we remember
anything before we're 5 years old and I
think it's because the brain is
optimizing to learn physics I think the
physics are just so important you just
like we don't need memory right now
physics are like fundamentals man if you
don't know physics you're gonna [__]
die like just you know walking down the
street right right so it's all physics I
think these are like new physics lessons
that that we find really fascinating um
you know what else people are really
interested in is these uh they call them
ASMR videos
oh% soothing things that are happening
we did this as an ad for my Ecom brand
so I was watching Tik toks and there's
these Tik toks that are these soothing
ASMR things the ones that uh I was
watching were like a bottle there
there's a bottle filled with Sands or
Mar sand or marble marbles so I think it
Marbles and it would they would roll the
glass bottle down a set of cement stairs
so you hear like the clink rolling like
a glass bottle rolling sound then you
hear the clink as it hits the stair and
then by the second or third stair it
cracks and then you hear marbles
bouncing like in synchronicity like down
the stairs and for some reason these
view these videos always have like 10
million 10 million views on them just
because they're like oddly satisfying to
watch and people just love that
combination of the visual plus the sound
and so we took that and we remixed that
with our product basically we we we
integrated it in with our product so
that the video starts with that rolling
thing and then we just sort of hijack
the video and show our product upon the
smash and way more people watch that
than if we just start with our product
even though it's a complete bait and
switch that's interesting yeah I mean if
you go up to someone on the street and
be like hey do you love physics do you
want to study Physics like no but that's
actually not the truth humans love
physics we all love physics we're
obsessed with physics and it starts at a
zero so interesting so yeah so this this
uh add to prevent drunk driving did the
you know all these these same things and
it worked so okay so here's a a modern
story so 2010 when we were were starting
golden hippo
my brother comes to me and he says hey
have you you heard of probiotics and and
I hadn't and I was like what are those
and he he says well you know you got all
these bacteria in you and I was like
okay what do you mean he's like you know
your microbiome I'm like what's that you
know he goes on to tell me that you know
you you take these probiotics which are
good beneficial bacteria supposed to do
something right so I take them and I
started having a lot more regular poops
I don't know who what I was eating
before but they started working and I
was like why why is this affecting me
I'm a pretty healthy guy I'm in pretty
good shape um this is this is actually
helping me out and I started looking
into it and I realized that all of these
Foods I was eating that I thought were
healthy because they said uh low fat or
whatever on them had sugars or
artificial sweeteners or things like
that pumped into them from the food
companies and they were on the name on
the labels under different names so you
don't know what they are you know like
super Gros or um right you know agave
nectar things like that you know like
you you and it could say zero sugars on
the label but the ingredients have these
substitutes yeah yeah but it's got Agave
it's got corn syrup it's got like you
know natural fruit juices you know all
those things are are sugars and so I
started digging into this and there was
some shady stuff man there was some some
experiments done where like like you
know the suar companies would would pay
a farmer to uh uh you know food is very
expensive for livestock and and Farmers
always dreamed that they could give
their livestock sugar instead of food
and they they'd be able to use that as a
nutrient so they could stop this big
food expense and like they do that they
try it and the cows would all die you
know and then they try to okay well
let's take the food and let's add sugar
and see what happens and then the cows
would still die you and then they they
bury the studies right and the the
artificial sweder things were even worse
so there was a company uh GD surl that
invented uh artificial sweetener called
aspartame it's now known as neutr site
what a lot of people don't know is when
they he came up with this artificial
sweetener they knew it'd be a billion
dollar product um because the sweetener
Market had already been built out they
started testing it on lab animals and
that lab animals were growing
tumors and the scientists got popped for
the first time ever that um the
government filed criminal charges
against a company for falsifying studies
because the scientists were cutting the
tumors out of the animals and sewing
them back up and saying oh no tumors
here and they got caught doing that wow
and so I found out about all this and I
was just like completely mystified and
so I wrote this presentation about this
and I talked about probiotics and how a
way to combat the artificial sweeteners
and sugars that are being pumped into
your foods that it'd be impossible for
you to uh discover them all you know is
to add good bacteria because those um
you know the bad bacteria growth that
that happens because of all this
consumption that makes the bad bacteria
get really frothy um need to be offset
by good bacteria and so I put this video
together and it went absolutely bananas
so uh it was seen by probably uh you
know 100 million people it's hard to
track uh but um the last we checked
there was over 100 million and this is
in a period of about four months Joe
Rogan tweeted it out and someone wrote
they're like Hey Joe do you realize this
is a actually an advertisement for a
probiotic and he wrote back oh yeah you
know I didn't see that till the end I
tweeted out before I I got to the end of
the video but you should go watch it or
something like that you know um and it
it created the biggest uh probiotic
brand in the world at the time and it
was because of this Ed educational
component showing people
that the your food supply is messed up
and you have something called a
microbiome that's getting affected by
your food supply and one way to Aid that
is with with probiotics and so if you
look at the Google transl we didn't have
in the 20s you know I'm sure if we could
do this for Google for the 20s and look
at like you know uh cigarettes right you
see like the big spike after the the uh
Easter Day Parade right um or VW Bug
you'd see the big spike uh after the uh
the think small campaign well we have
this now so if you look at probiotics
you know probiotics were gaining some
steam here and here's where um our ad
comes online is uh Keybiotics was our
brand so look at the general Spike and
probiotics okay so what what happened
there well you can see basically the day
we get kicked off of
Google and it goes down and uh you see
the trend line line goes down
too um but then you see it it it goes
back up again and you know this is what
we launched our next probiotic brand
perfect
biotics uh you know did did okay it
wasn't the the huge Banger of success
that that Keybiotics
was but fear
not met a guy named Dr gundry in 2016 we
launched the brand with him and look at
look at these Spike wies look at the
probiotic Spike lines compared with with
the term gundry and the reason syn
gundry and some days is when the the
campaigns would be running really strong
you know the the videoos running running
a lot that's where the the searches
would go
crazy and that was because Dr gundry is
out there with with our educational
presentations talking about the
microbiome and talking about probiotics
and prebiotics and really just educating
the world on this stuff and
you know we didn't bring probiotics to
America or or anything like that uh but
I like to think we were probably a
company that taught more people than
anyone about the microbiome and now you
know the probiotic Trends uh you know
keeps keeps going and I think it just
keeps going uh up and to the right if
you if you find the the current data you
know and by now the uh Market has
changed you know I talked about uh I did
a Twitter thread a ways back I talked
about the three stages of a product
market so there's Clueless
which is when you need to create uh the
the the marketing wave because your your
Market knows nothing about the the
product right so back then when I
started no one knew anything about
probiotics so if I just said like hey
here's probiotics try them out no one
would have cared but I started with
something they did care about was was
like hey is your digestion messed up are
you having irregularity at the bathroom
well here's the reason why and then the
next stage of the market is um is
curious where someone's probably heard
the term
probiotics and and you can jump R and so
while my ads in 2013 2014 were starting
with Digestive Health I had an ad in
2018 I believe it was and the headline
was doctor says throw your probiotics in
the
trash and enough people knew about
probiotics by then they were like oh
that's wait wait I heard these are good
for you you know right and then you
click on it and it goes on to talk about
how most probiotics don't have enough
strains of Po see and also you know
prebiotics are important and this and
that you know so that's just knowing the
market where it was and and where you
need to jump in and then the next level
the uh Market is is
saturation and that's kind of where the
probiotics Market is now I'm not
launching new probiotics uh you know
every time I go to conference someone
comes up to me they're like hey I'm
launching a probiotic I me good luck you
know it's it's pretty commoditized by
now but there's still some that have
have broken through with with strong
campaigns amazing and so see these are
the seven High Jacks I'll read them out
here so number one make it about them so
that's make it about the customer and
the benefits that they're going to get
number two make it an event that's the
um you know nothing attracts a crowd
like a crowd um then number three is a
powerful demonstration so that's the PT
Barum that's the elevator uh with the
axe that's the sword cutting through the
bullet um that's the drinking dirty
water um show unquestionable proof so
that's using experts like doctors or uh
influencers Plus
um you know like you said he was willing
to be in the elevator while the thing
was cut you know that's a demonstration
of proof five change a daily behavior
and I think this was change an existing
daily behavior
um is that right or is it change any
daily Behavior I mean it could it could
be either you know okay so and so this
is like bulletproof getting you to add
something into your coffee something you
already doing or like breakfast uh
having a hearty breakfast as the start
of your day versus you know just a c
coffee in in a in a bread roll yeah so
he hijacked Dave hijacked the daily
behavior and what we did with probiotics
is we change the daily Behavior we uh
encourage them to take something every
day so then six is sell the dream that's
the the movie star smile that's
underneath that film if only you would
start brushing your teeth or this is uh
Craig pooping regularly because he now
takes uh you know probiotics prebiotics
that's the dream and then number seven
is help them um
uh be a rebel or feel Superior and so
that's you know be able to to stick a
middle finger to the man whoever the man
is whether it's Nike or it's uh you know
women not having equal rights or
whatever um give them the tools and the
badge to to feel like they're Superior
and uh in a rebellion a part of a
rebellion that's right amazing well said
well said you're you're uh good student
yeah well this is I mean the stuff
that's in here is um I guess like this
is rare in two ways number one I took
marketing classes in college and I had
marketing professors none of my
marketing professors had ever done what
you did they never created a category
they never did a billion dollars in
sales they never sat there and crafted
um you know even this presentation when
we talked three days ago it was going to
be like marketing throughout the decades
no and you were like no that's not going
to be the title I got to think of
something good you come back with seven
seven human hijacks how marketers have
hijacked your brain and I'm like oh God
just seeing you go from two days ago
with no title or a shitty working title
to like a really strong title is seeing
somebody in action or hearing you what
you did with the the probiotics market
so number one the opportunity to have a
teacher who's actually a master of the
game is so rare so obviously I'm sitting
up in my seat I'm paying attention
number two any one of these like I'm
thinking as you were talking my brain
was like having almost a hard time
listening cuz I'm firing ideas for any
of my companies on like oh a powerful
demonstration how could we show this in
a way that's exaggerated and would would
would almost be kind of shocking or add
some drama to what we're doing versus
just saying the feature or saying it's
good like now how could we like do do a
powerful demonstration that would give
people unquestionable proof right so I
couldn't even like stop my brain from
moving while I'm doing this now that's I
don't know that's the entrepreneur in me
but I think there's a lot of people who
are listening that are like that that
like if you paid attention to this even
one of these hijacks could like
literally like change the trajectory of
your company so anyways I appreciate you
putting this together this is kind of a
this is amazing to me um I don't know
how other people going to feel about
this but like as as the only student in
the room right now I was uh you know I'm
pumped about this this is this is great
well I I appreciate the kind words and
you know if they as they say if you can
change the life of just one person right
then your job is complete so I'll take
it all right well you did
it this has been a master class uh for
sure so thanks for thanks everyone for
watching that's the pod
[Music]
h